I'm waiting for the three guys, I mean Jason, Sean and Will, but I mean I don't know what happened with them, maybe the equipment doesn't work, or maybe everything doesn't work, who knows what's going on here, but welcome to Spotless! Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Jason, what did you do last night? I know what you did. You went to the Lakers game.
我在等那三个人，我是说杰森、肖恩和威尔，但我不知道他们出了什么事，也许是设备坏了，或者什么都坏了，谁知道这里发生了什么，但欢迎来到Spotless！不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。杰森，你昨晚做了什么？我知道你做了什么。你去看湖人队的比赛了。
Yes, had a great, great time. Really fun. I hosted 3-11-year-olds. One of which was my daughter. Was it fun? time, really fun. I hosted 311-year-olds, one of which was my daughter. Was it fun? It was really fun. Did they win? They did win. They tried to lose, but they fixed it there at the end.
是的，玩得非常非常开心。真的很有趣。我招待了3个11岁的孩子。其中一个是我的女儿。好玩吗？真的很有趣。我招待了3个11岁的孩子，其中一个是我的女儿。好玩吗？真的很有趣。他们赢了吗？他们确实赢了。他们本来想输的，但最后还是扳回来了。
And it was a hoot. I've heard people describe fun things as. That's fun. That's fun. Yeah, I like going to Lakers game. And then today, I was going to do some cooking, but then I heard that I think Sean, maybe you might have mentioned to Amanda that no one's interested in eating what I, or was it you will?
而且非常热闹。我听过人们形容有趣的事情是。那很有趣。那很有趣。是的，我喜欢去看湖人队的比赛。然后今天，我本来打算做点饭，但我听说，我想肖恩，也许你可能跟阿曼达提过，没人对吃我做的东西感兴趣，还是你威尔？
No one's interested in Sean. That's what I was planning on cooking, apparently got kind of a want-want. You, so, wow. And Amanda said what, Amanda said what you were planning on cooking in Sean said nobody wants that. Yeah, I said nobody wants Who wouldn't want yeah, please tell me what a gooey peanut butter chocolate chip bar. Yeah, oh sorry gooey pumpkin chocolate chip bar. Well no the only okay, and then the other thing was yeah That because nobody wants pumpkin and I ran berry lemon bar. No, that's right. Nobody wants pumpkin and anything and nobody wants cranberry and anything.
没人对肖恩感兴趣。这就是我当时打算做的，显然有点不受欢迎。你，所以，哇。阿曼达说了什么，阿曼达说了你打算做什么，肖恩说没人想要那个。是的，我说没人想要。谁会不想要呢，请告诉我，黏糊糊的花生酱巧克力豆棒。是的，哦抱歉，黏糊糊的南瓜巧克力豆棒。好吧，不，唯一的问题是，没人想要南瓜，我做了蔓越莓柠檬棒。不，没错。没人想要南瓜做的任何东西，也没人想要蔓越莓做的任何东西。
And apparently the gale said, all of them said that also you can't have lemon in a dessert that was according to our hostess. What? So I guess a real bullet dodged. I guess so. Yeah. You know what all these freaks on the New York Times top 10 desserts, bullet dodged. I guess so. Yeah. You know what, all these freaks on the New York Times top 10 desserts, Lister thinking.
显然盖尔说了，他们所有人都说，你不能在甜点里放柠檬，这是我们女主人的意思。什么？所以我猜真是躲过一劫。我想是吧。是的。你知道《纽约时报》十大甜点里的那些怪胎，躲过一劫。我想是吧。是的。你知道吗，所有这些《纽约时报》十大甜点里的怪胎，都在想。
What, what, what, you know what I'm saying? Oh, is that, was that? Wait, but this is like, Amanda said, Amanda said that every year you do this and that you, you like to cook a few things here and there. And I knew nothing about this. I did not either. I didn't either.
什么，什么，什么，你知道我在说什么吗？哦，是那样吗，那是？等等，但这就像，阿曼达说，阿曼达说你每年都这么做，而且你，你喜欢在这里或那里做几样东西。我对这些一无所知。我也不知道。我也不知道。
I had forgotten, but I guess she says that I, this is what I do every year, but you know, I think I, I bake some stuff because I want to. You inspired me. I want to. Oh, that's good. You inspired me. I was so, like, you've done cheesecake, you've done brownies, you've done, you're going
我忘了，但我猜她说我，这就是我每年做的事情，但你知道，我想我，我烤了一些东西是因为我想。你激励了我。我想。哦，那很好。你激励了我。我当时，就像，你做过芝士蛋糕，你做过布朗尼，你做过，你打算
to do eclare's next week. I think you did last night was good. That little, that thing you did. Oh, last night I did not like that. I made, I made this new thing last night. I didn't love it too much, too sweet. But Jay, I made a box of Mac and cheese last night at 1030 because it's too big of a gummy and I feel like today.
下周做泡芙。我想你昨晚做的很好。那个，你做的那个东西。哦，昨晚我不喜欢那个。我做了，我昨晚做了这个新东西。我不太喜欢，太甜了。但是杰，我昨晚10点半做了一盒通心粉奶酪，因为它太黏了，我感觉今天。
So, after a full dinner, he went home and ate a full box and has a neat and all day because he's been there. I almost took a picture of it and said it's here. I mean, the gummy wiped out. Yeah, I didn't have the gummy wipe out. Still recovering. Listen, I tell you what, I tell you who did not eat an entire box
所以，吃完一顿完整的晚餐后，他回家吃了一整盒，而且整天都没吃东西，因为他一直在那儿。我差点拍了张照片说它在这儿。我是说，那个软糖让我崩溃了。是的，我没吃软糖崩溃。还在恢复中。听着，我告诉你，我告诉你昨晚没吃一整盒
of mac and cheese last night was our guest. Because this is somebody who has famously taken care of himself his entire life. This is a person who has made a mark in every single thing he's decided to go into in his life. It's pretty hard to have lived in Western culture and not know who this man is. Pretty hard. Do I sound very Canadian when I say that?
通心粉奶酪的人是我们的嘉宾。因为这是一个一生中都非常出名地照顾自己的人。这是一个在他决定从事的每一件事上都留下了印记的人。生活在西方文化中而不认识这个人是很难的。很难。我这么说听起来很像加拿大人吗？
I said it almost easily. Or Chicago. Like you from Chicago. This person, his, is such a part of our sort of cultural fabric at risk of embarrassing him when I say that, but it is true. He over the last 40, 50 years, he has been in absolutely every seemingly every walk of life. He has done everything from being an author to being a incredible, one of the biggest film stars ever to being a politician.
我几乎很自然地说出来了。或者芝加哥。就像你来自芝加哥。这个人，他的，是我们某种文化结构的一部分，冒着让他尴尬的风险我这么说，但这是真的。在过去的40、50年里，他绝对出现在每一个看似每一个生活领域。他做过一切，从作家到有史以来最伟大的电影明星之一，再到政治家。
He is not, he refuses to be categorized as a self-made man because I think that he claims that he's had a lot of help along the way, but it sure seems like he did a lot. He's done a lot of heavy lifting on his own, especially he did a lot of heavy lifting when he won, I'm gonna say, Senator Tornado. Senator Olympia, he was also a four-time Mr. University, he's also the 38th governor
他不是，他拒绝被归类为白手起家的人，因为我认为他声称他在这一路上得到了很多帮助，但他看起来确实做了很多。他自己做了很多重活，特别是当他赢得，我要说，龙卷风参议员。奥林匹亚参议员，他还是四届宇宙先生，他还是第38任州长
of the state of California. Got it. Guys, it's Arnold Schwarzenegger. Hello, that's so, hello, it's Arnold Schwarzenegger! Oh! Hello, though. Hello, now Mr. Arnold. What a guest. What a guest. Wow, and I couldn't,
加利福尼亚州。明白了。伙计们，是阿诺德·施瓦辛格。你好，太，你好，是阿诺德·施瓦辛格！哦！你好。你好，阿诺德先生。多么棒的嘉宾。多么棒的嘉宾。哇，我不能，
because Jason Guest and I couldn't even say you're a number one New York Times selling a number one author, you know, I mean, just, the list is just keeps going, but Jason Guest it. So Mr. Schwarzeneg and Edgar nice to meet you. Well, thank you very much for the nice introduction and I really appreciate that the build up, but I mean, it's so entertaining to listen to you guys talk.
因为杰森·盖斯特，我甚至不能说你是《纽约时报》排名第一的畅销书作家，你知道，我是说，只是，名单还在继续，但杰森·盖斯特做到了。所以施瓦辛格先生，很高兴见到你。好吧，非常感谢你这么好的介绍，我真的很感激这个铺垫，但我是说，听你们聊天太有趣了。
Oh, yeah. I mean, I've very, really had conversations like that. I mean, that is Jason Mac and cheese. What about this? Mac and cheese and it's four o'clock and I'm late. It's not one of our best, but you know what? You've really brought it up. Yeah, but I mean, it's like it's wild. I mean, it's like, but the funny thing is I don't know you, Jason, and I don't know
哦，是的。我是说，我真的很少有那样的对话。我是说，那是杰森的通心粉奶酪。这个怎么样？通心粉奶酪，现在四点了，我迟到了。这不是我们最好的，但你知道吗？你真的把它提出来了。是的，但我是说，这太疯狂了。我是说，这就像，但有趣的是我不认识你，杰森，我也不认识
will, even though I admire your work on television and then the movies that I've seen and the entertain me thoroughly. But Sean, I know personally. I mean, Sean is someone that I've met in the night. I think it was back in the 90s, the family of mistaken, know he was out here and some of it even helped me with Maria together decorate the house. Would I remember? Yeah, generally positive meeting. Yeah, we have very very very positive. He's a really he's a really positive guy. Well, so I love it, but I mean when I hear this this food kind of story. Yeah, it's exciting. What a drama.
威尔，尽管我很钦佩你在电视和电影里的作品，它们让我彻底地娱乐了。但肖恩，我个人认识。我是说，肖恩是我在90年代认识的人，我想是在那之后，那个被误解的家庭，知道他当时在那儿，甚至有人帮我和玛丽亚一起装饰房子。我会记得吗？是的，非常积极的会面。是的，我们非常非常积极。他是一个非常非常积极的人。好吧，所以我喜欢它，但我是说当我听到这个食物故事时。是的，太令人兴奋了。多么戏剧性。
You got to help. Oh my God. I ate it kind of cock. Mac and cheese. And they didn't feel good. And that's why. And this is like terrible. The world is coming to an end.
你得帮帮我。天哪。我吃了一点通心粉奶酪。感觉不太好。这就是为什么。这就像太糟糕了。世界末日要来了。
And it's like, oh, what a sad story. That's it. But more or more, I feel so sorry for him now. Thank you. I mean, I don't even know how to recuperate. Oh, no. Where do you hear what do you what do you ate the rest of the 24 hours? I wanted to start this whole interview here in the positive way, in a positive way. Then I get this beating there by the house. Well, things went from last night on 10 o'clock. I mean, Sean, what has gone on? I may
这就像，哦，多么悲伤的故事。就是这样。但越来越多，我现在真为他感到难过。谢谢。我是说，我甚至不知道该怎么恢复。哦，不。你听听你24小时剩下的时间里吃了什么？我想以积极的方式开始整个采访。然后我在房子那儿受到了打击。好吧，事情从昨晚10点开始。我是说，肖恩，发生了什么？我可能
give the come. I don't know what you live now, but I mean you are the endosanulous. I'm in the same house you saw you came to visit me. Okay, good. So then is it about time you get back together again. Yes. And get that so I can go and make you one of the steaks over here so you don't get sick and tired of the food and tend to track it. Now just to come over for steak dinner, what for chicken dinner, all for something maybe vegan. Well, that's our time, Arnold. Thank you so much. Let me just say this. Having shown it's bad enough hearing what you went through last night,
给那个。我不知道你现在住哪儿，但我是说你是那个荒谬的人。我在你来拜访我的同一所房子里。好的，很好。那么是时候你们再聚在一起了。是的。把它弄好，这样我就可以去给你做一份牛排，这样你就不会对食物感到厌倦和疲惫了。现在只是过来吃牛排晚餐，或者鸡肉晚餐，或者也许是纯素食。好吧，阿诺德，我们的时间到了。让我说这个。有肖恩在，听到你昨晚经历的事情已经够糟糕了，
but having Arnold Schwarzenegger recited back to you is one of the best things that I've ever heard in my life, because it does really put it in a different light. Like, right, it makes it sound so crazy. And how disappointed he is in your show reactions? It's just like any dad. No, no. Arnold, how long do you think Sean?
但让阿诺德·施瓦辛格把它复述给你听是我一生中听过的最好的事情之一，因为它确实把它放在了一个不同的角度。就像，对，这让它听起来太疯狂了。他对你的表演反应有多失望？就像任何父亲一样。不，不。阿诺德，你觉得肖恩多久？
I just thought it was funny, because then you guys all went off and talked about, but with you eight, and the things that you're doing at home when you're cooking and stuff. So I said, well, maybe I've plugged in here to a cooking show or something like that. Maybe you guys have a good choice.
我只是觉得这很有趣，因为你们都跑去谈论，但关于你吃的，以及你在家里做饭时做的事情。所以我说，好吧，也许我插进了一个烹饪节目之类的。也许你们有一个好的选择。
It's been called worse. Well, how long do you think Sean? Arnold, how long do you think Sean can get away with eating like this? Because isn't it true? As you get older, doesn't it? You're a tablism. Yeah, there were tablism slows down such that if you keep eating the same thing you ate last year, you will gain, I think it's three pounds a year if you just eat
它被叫得更难听过。好吧，你觉得肖恩多久？阿诺德，你觉得肖恩能这样吃多久？因为这不是真的吗？随着年龄的增长，不是吗？你的新陈代谢。是的，新陈代谢变慢了，如果你继续吃去年吃的东西，你会增加，我想是一年三磅，如果你只是吃
the same thing every year. Like your metabolic rate goes down such that you've got to eliminate three pounds a year from what you eat. Is that right? Yeah, it sounds good mathematically, but you just said. But I think it's very hard to do because I can tell you for myself, I have to go on bike rides every day, I work out every day because it's very hard to kind of stop eating and to just go on severe diets like some people do, I've never done that.
每年吃同样的东西。就像你的代谢率下降了，所以你必须从你吃的东西中减少三磅。是这样吗？是的，数学上听起来不错，但你刚才说的。但我认为这很难做到，因为我可以告诉你我自己，我必须每天骑自行车，我每天锻炼，因为很难停止进食，像有些人那样进行严格的节食，我从来没做过。
So of course you develop a little bit of stomach because of that. But I think the key thing is to keep it in moderation and not to gain too much weight because otherwise it's made for you, you know, for your heart and for your health and family. Makes it sound good. You gain a little bit of stomach. That's it. Something that doesn't sound as nasty. No.
所以当然你会因为那个长出一点肚子。但我认为关键是保持适度，不要增加太多体重，否则这对你，你知道，对你的心脏和你的健康和家庭来说是注定的。听起来不错。你长了一点肚子。就是这样。听起来没那么恶心的东西。不。
If I can ask you, because I wonder, there's so much stuff I want to talk about before we get to this, but now that we're on the subject, because like I said, you're famously known, you know, seven-time Mr. Olympia, four-time Mr. Universe, you've done it all known for your physique for many years and award winning physique. And you said that you still work out so you're riding the bike, you're doing stuff. I'm so interested. What does working out for you because you're not competing in that way anymore? What is working out now for you look like?
如果我可以问你，因为我想知道，在我们要谈这个之前有很多我想谈的事情，但既然我们谈到了这个话题，因为就像我说的，你非常出名，你知道，七届奥林匹亚先生，四届宇宙先生，你做过这一切，多年来以你的体格闻名，获奖的体格。你说你仍然在锻炼，所以你在骑自行车，你在做一些事情。我非常感兴趣。对你来说锻炼是什么，因为你不再以那种方式竞争了？现在的锻炼对你来说是什么样的？
I'm literally, I just want to know selfishly for me. I go on a bike ride, I ride the bike on on 45 minutes to an hour a day and I work out with weights. It calls Jim, I would send him on 45 minutes a day. But very light, nothing heavy, because I had heart surgery in 1997. And then the doctors were telling me that they should stop the heavy, heavy lifting, because it's not good for your valves.
我真的，我只是自私地想知道。我去骑自行车，我每天骑45分钟到一个小时，我用哑铃锻炼。它叫健身房，我会送他每天45分钟。但非常轻，没什么重的，因为我在1997年做了心脏手术。然后医生告诉我，他们应该停止大重量的举重，因为它对你的瓣膜不好。
They get kind of, you know, they wipe out the sooner. And so therefore, you know, I just started lifting less weights, more reps and stuff like that. But everyone got regularly, but this, you know, as you get older, it's kind of like, how the hell do you hold on to some of the stuff that you once had? And it's really, it's tough because it's... Wait, so if you do like free weights and lift weights like that, it's bad for your valves of your heart or for your heart. If, no, not for normally for heart,
它们变得有点，你知道，它们很快就报废了。所以因此，你知道，我只是开始举更轻的重量，更多的次数之类的。但每个人都定期，但这，你知道，随着年龄的增长，这有点像，你到底是怎么保持你曾经拥有的东西的？这真的很难，因为它是……等等，所以如果你做自由重量和举重之类的，这对你的心脏瓣膜或心脏不好。如果，不，通常对心脏不好，
but I mean, it is when you have a valve surgery, what evolve and pulmonary valve. You don't want to put that much pressure on it, you know, when you really bench press heavy or to heavy dead lift the squats and all that stuff. You're good, John. And you put a lot of pressure on that valve and it's unnecessary.
但我是说，当你做瓣膜手术时，什么瓣膜和肺动脉瓣。你不想给它施加那么大的压力，你知道，当你真的做大重量卧推或大重量硬拉深蹲之类的东西时。你很好，约翰。你给那个瓣膜施加了很大的压力，这是没必要的。
So the idea is, is let's use less weight and therefore, you know, you don't have to switch the valve and it's unnecessary. So the idea is, is let's use less weight and therefore, you know, you don't have to switch the valve. I mean, after 23 years later, I still had to exchange it anyway and had another surgery and all that stuff, but the bottom line is you don't want to abuse it, you know, it's okay. The valve, like, everything is like a tire. You have a certain amount of miles and then it just have to switch, you know. Also, it's midsection or mind you have a tire. You have a certain amount of miles, and then it just have to switch. Also, it's midsection or a mind you have a tire. It's a whole gym. Yeah, let's get back to Gold's Gym.
所以这个想法是，让我们使用更轻的重量，因此，你知道，你不必更换瓣膜，这是没必要的。我是说，23年后，我还是不得不更换它，做了另一次手术之类的，但底线是你不想滥用它，你知道，没关系。瓣膜，就像，一切都像轮胎。你有一定的里程，然后它就必须更换，你知道。还有，它是中段或头脑，你有轮胎。你有一定的里程，然后它就必须更换。还有，它是中段或头脑，你有轮胎。这是一个完整的健身房。是的，让我们回到黄金健身房。
Can you walk me through that process? So you walk into the gym there, you're ready to get your pump on. You've got a pump? Yeah, so you got your puncher ticket, you've got 10 more visits left. And then you get to your favorite machine, and there's some, some gemoc on that. And's he's sitting there he's running through his emails he's
你能带我了解那个过程吗？所以你走进那里的健身房，你准备好让你的肌肉充血了。你充血了吗？是的，所以你拿到了你的票，你还剩下10次访问机会。然后你到了你最喜欢的机器，那里有一些，一些健身白痴在那儿。他坐在那儿，他正在浏览他的电子邮件，他
still sitting on the thing and it's he's he's he's he's he's he's he's he's giving me Harry eyeball like buddy let's go I want to get in there or or you have a special section ready for it because you've been going there for years right? No I mean does the reason to approach it that way. I just always been someone sitting on the machine, or when someone works out on the machine, I just ask, you mind if I work in with you. Imagine if I go over there. While they're resting, you do your rep. Well, yeah, because everyone walks around, so what that basically means is, if you do
仍然坐在那个东西上，他正在给我那种讨厌的眼神，像伙计，走吧，我想进去，或者或者你有一个专门的区域准备好了，因为你已经在那里去了几年了，对吧？不，我是说，没有理由那样接近它。我一直是一个坐在机器上的人，或者当有人在机器上锻炼时，我只是问，你介意我和你一起用吗。想象一下如果我走过去。当他们休息时，你做你的次数。好吧，是的，因为每个人都在走动，所以这基本上意味着，如果你做
your set, don't just sit there, maybe while you're resting, and then you can cut in again after that, because I go from machine to machine, the machine. And so it's easy for me to just ask people if I can cut in and then what an happy to do that. So there's no problem with that. It's just a matter of attitude without saying to someone, get off the bench. I'm going to make a, sorry, so I'm just gonna just to follow up on that. I make a safe guess that you're doing well enough to have your own set of weights at the
你的组，不要只是坐在那儿，也许当你休息时，然后你可以在那之后再次切入，因为我从机器到机器，到机器。所以对我来说，问人们我是否可以切入很容易，然后他们很乐意那样做。所以没问题。这只是态度的问题，而不是对某人说，从长凳上下来。我要做一个，抱歉，所以我只是要跟进那个。我做一个安全的猜测，你做得足够好，可以在家里有你自己的重量
house there. You just like to go down the goals to bond with the fellas. I have a fully equipped gym at home. Yeah. And during, you know, COVID, I trained all of the time, just at home. But I am a company queen. And so that means that I love company, whatever I do. I don't like to go out for lunch for myself, I like to eat with somebody, I don't like to go to football games or the soccer game for myself, I like to go with somebody or with a bunch of guys or people. And the same is also with working out.
房子那儿。你只是喜欢去黄金健身房和伙计们建立联系。我在家里有一个设备齐全的健身房。是的。在，你知道，新冠期间，我一直都在训练，就在家里。但我是一个公司女王。所以这意味着我喜欢公司，无论我做什么。我不喜欢一个人出去吃午饭，我喜欢和某人一起吃，我不喜欢一个人去看足球比赛或足球比赛，我喜欢和某人或一群人一起去。锻炼也是一样。
I get a lot of energy when I go to a gym and see everyone else working out and sweating and training hard. It makes me inspired and then I want to work out too. So it's just a lot of sense. Yeah, because I was going to ask you like, even at this age, nobody loves to go to the gym. Now, there's not a lot of people that love to work out or exercise, but what is it that, because it's hard work, like, if I can skip it,
当我走进健身房看到其他人都在锻炼、流汗和努力训练时，我得到了很多能量。这让我受到启发，然后我也想锻炼。所以这很有意义。是的，因为我本来想问你，就像，即使在这个年龄，也没人喜欢去健身房。现在，没有多少人喜欢锻炼或运动，但这是什么，因为这是艰苦的工作，就像，如果我可以跳过它，
I'll skip it. But like, you know, what's the draw to keep doing it now and always so that you don't pop, Sean? I know, but I'm like, but to work at that, that the intensity level that you're still working out at is It's a decision. It's not that intense. It's not that intense I mean, but first of all, I love working out. Yeah, I know why because it just makes me feel good I understand I mean, I work out it makes me feel good
我会跳过它。但就像，你知道，现在继续做它的吸引力是什么，总是这样，这样你就不会崩溃，肖恩？我知道，但我像，但要以你仍然在锻炼的强度水平工作，这是这是一个决定。没那么激烈。没那么激烈，我是说，但首先，我喜欢锻炼。是的，我知道为什么，因为它让我感觉很好。我明白，我是说，我锻炼，它让我感觉很好。
I always say the people say when I get up in the morning and I Bicycle down to the gym, I feel like I'm, I'm bisaking through a black and white movie and then all of a sudden when I'm finished working out and bisaking back, I feel like it's a color movie. It's a whole world, it's more colorful. I feel more positive. It's like the rainbow UCF, do you finish macaroni? She's only get on a bicycle to go to get a black and white shake.
我总是说人们说当我早上起床骑自行车去健身房时，我觉得我正在骑自行车穿过一部黑白电影，然后当我锻炼完骑自行车回来时，我觉得它是一部彩色电影。整个世界，它更丰富多彩。我感觉更积极。就像彩虹UCF，你吃完通心粉了吗？她只骑自行车去买黑白奶昔。
That's the only one. We're black and white cookie. That's the last one. That's really what he's doing. That's so true. I just love it. I love the feeling that I get from that. It's addictive. So I'm addicted to working out. I have to say. So to me, it's not kind of a chore because I know why I'm doing it. I want to look half decent at my age, even though it's beautiful. It looks beautiful, aren't it? No, but the music. The beard looks gorgeous too.
那是唯一的一个。我们黑白饼干。那是最后一个。那确实是他正在做的。太真实了。我只是喜欢它。我喜欢我从中得到的感觉。它让人上瘾。所以我对锻炼上瘾了。我必须说。所以对我来说，这不像是一种苦差事，因为我知道我为什么这样做。我想在我这个年纪看起来还不错，尽管它很美。它看起来很美，阿诺德？不，但音乐。胡子看起来也很华丽。
Look at the beard is gorgeous. It looks really good. Thank you. But Jason, let me tell you something. First of all, I just want to let you know that you with your show OZAK. I mean, you have blown me away. You know, there's three of my favorite shows, with OZAK and Arcos and Yellowstone, the Dictator that watched.
看胡子很华丽。看起来真的很好。谢谢。但是杰森，让我告诉你一些事情。首先，我只是想让你知道，你和你的节目《黑钱胜地》。我是说，你让我大吃一惊。你知道，有三个我最喜欢的节目，有《黑钱胜地》和《毒枭》和《黄石》，我看过的《独裁者》。
And it was just nice coming. I mean, talking about like, Dictiv to working out, I was addicted to watching your show, Yeah, because you did such a world Unbelievable job and that it was really fantastic. You're very very nice to do the know that how much you entertain me and how much pleasure I've brought to me watching this watching this makes me shy. Thank you though. Oh Jason entertain him right now. I get I get small You want you I can I can talk in the Marty voice ready ready? Hi, it's me, I'm just talking. Oh, Marty. That's Marty.
而且这很好。我是说，谈到像对锻炼上瘾，我沉迷于看你的节目，是的，因为你做得太棒了，令人难以置信的工作，这真的很棒。你非常非常客气，不知道你给了我多少娱乐，以及看这个看这个给我带来了多少快乐，这让我害羞。谢谢你。哦，杰森，现在娱乐他。我变得很小，你想要你，我可以，我可以用马蒂的声音说话，准备好了吗？嗨，是我，我只是在说话。哦，马蒂。那是马蒂。
And we will be right back. This episode is brought to you in part by Rocket Money. It's nearly 2024 and it appears that we can't buy things anymore. We can only subscribe to them, right? There are subscriptions for everything these days, from streaming services to razors, fitness programs, to pet food, even bacon of the month. It's no wonder it can feel impossible to keep tabs
我们马上回来。本集部分由Rocket Money赞助。快到2024年了，看起来我们不能再买东西了。我们只能订阅它们，对吧？这些天什么都有订阅，从流媒体服务到剃须刀，健身计划到宠物食品，甚至是每月的培根。难怪很难跟上
on what you're paying for every month. That's why you should check out Rocket Money. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. With Rocket Money, you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button.
你每月支付的费用。这就是为什么你应该看看Rocket Money。Rocket Money是一个个人理财应用程序，它可以找到并取消你不想要的订阅，监控你的支出，并帮助你在一个地方降低账单。使用Rocket Money，你可以只需按一下按钮，轻松取消你不想要的订阅。
No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service, Rocket Money does all the work for you. Rocket Money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill, and Rocket Money takes care of the rest. Rocket Money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place, recommends custom budgets based on your past spending, and they money takes care of the rest. Rocket money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place, recommends custom budgets
不再有漫长的等待时间或与客户服务的烦人电子邮件，Rocket Money为你完成所有工作。Rocket Money甚至可以为你协商降低账单，最高可达20%。你所要做的就是拍一张你的账单照片，Rocket Money会处理剩下的事情。Rocket Money还让你在一个地方监控你所有的支出，根据你过去的支出推荐自定义预算，他们钱会处理剩下的事情。Rocket Money还让你在一个地方监控你所有的支出，推荐自定义预算
based on your past spending, and they'll even send you notifications when you've reached your spending limits. With over 5 million users and counting, Rocket money has helped save its customers an average of $720 a year, and $1 billion in total savings so far. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Council your unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocketmoney.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from HelloFresh.
基于你过去的支出，他们甚至会在你达到支出限额时向你发送通知。拥有超过500万用户且还在增加，Rocket Money已经帮助其客户平均每年节省720美元，到目前为止总共节省了10亿美元。不要再把钱浪费在你不用东西上了。取消你不想要的订阅，通过访问rocketmoney.com/smartless以简单的方式管理你的钱。那是rocketmoney.com/smartless rocketmoney.com/smartless。Smartless获得HelloFresh的支持。
Whether your resolution is to save money, eat better or stress less, HelloFresh is here to help you do all three. Say hello to your most delicious year yet with fresh ingredients and chef-crafted recipes at a price you'll like delivered right to your door. Each Hello Fresh box is packed with farm fresh ingredients and everything arrives pre-portioned right to your doorstep for less hassle
无论你的决心是省钱、吃得更好还是减少压力，HelloFresh都在这里帮助你完成这三件事。用新鲜的食材和厨师精心制作的食谱，以你喜欢的价格直接送到你家门口，迎接你最美味的一年。每个Hello Fresh盒子都装满了农场新鲜的食材，一切都预先分好送到你的家门口，减少麻烦
and less wasted food. So you're resolved to actually sit down and eat dinner around the table, but what do you do about those nights when your schedule is packed? Turn to HelloFresh's lineup of quick and easy meals, including their 15 minute recipes designed to help minimize meal-time stress. So you know what I love?
和减少食物浪费。所以你决心真正坐下来在餐桌旁吃晚餐，但当你的日程安排很满时，你该怎么办？转向HelloFresh的快速简便餐系列，包括他们旨在帮助最大限度地减少用餐时间压力的15分钟食谱。所以你知道我喜欢什么吗？
I love the Rapid Stir Fry beef, you know why? It's rapid like me, and it's a little spicy like me. Hello, HelloFresh. Go to HelloFresh.com slash smartless free and use code SmartlessFree for free breakfast for life. One breakfast item per box while subscription is active. Get free breakfast for life and support the show while you're at it. Just go to hellofresh.com slash Smartless Free with Code Smartless Free.
我喜欢快速炒牛肉，你知道为什么吗？它像我一样快，而且像我一样有点辣。你好，HelloFresh。去HelloFresh.com/smartlessfree并使用代码SmartlessFree获得终身免费早餐。订阅有效期间每盒一份早餐项目。获得终身免费早餐并在此过程中支持节目。只需去hellofresh.com/SmartlessFree并使用代码SmartlessFree。
Hello fresh, America's number one meal kit. Smartless fans, listen up. Have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show, Add Free and One Week Early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership? That's right, all your favorite, smart-less episodes can be heard on Amazon Music, Add Free, and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all you can listen to your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad
Hello Fresh，美国排名第一的餐包。Smartless粉丝，听好了。你听说过你可以用你的Prime会员资格在Amazon Music上免费且提前一周收听这个节目的剧集吗？没错，你所有最喜欢的Smartless剧集都可以在Amazon Music上免费收听，而且你总是第一个收看我们新剧集的人，这样你就可以向你的朋友吹嘘了。但这还不是全部，你可以收听你其他最喜欢的节目，比如，我不知道，Bad
Dates and Just Jack and Will, Early and Add Free, too. They also have favorites like The Daily, Pardon My Take, and Up First, all without any ads. You know what this means? Uninterrupted listings, so no more cliffhangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcasts, so we know they definitely have something for you, and it's already included in your prime membership. The list now all you need to do is go to Amazon.com slash smartless.
Dates和Just Jack and Will，也提前且免费。他们还有像The Daily, Pardon My Take和Up First这样的最爱，全部没有广告。你知道这意味着什么吗？不间断的收听，所以不再有悬念。Amazon Music提供最多的无广告顶级播客，所以我们知道他们肯定有适合你的东西，而且它已经包含在你的Prime会员资格中了。现在列表你所要做的就是去Amazon.com/smartless。
That's Amazon.com slash smartless, or download the Amazon Music app. It's just that easy. Alright, back to the show. the Amazon Music app, it's just that easy. All right, back to the show. So, Arnold, I mentioned in the intro all the things you've done and everything that you've done, every sort of thing that you've decided to get into, you've been successful and you started with bodybuilding. That's what initially I gather,
那是Amazon.com/smartless，或者下载Amazon Music应用程序。就是这么简单。好了，回到节目。Amazon Music应用程序，就是这么简单。好了，回到节目。所以，阿诺德，我在介绍中提到了你所做的一切以及你所做的一切，你决定从事的每一种事情，你都成功了，你从健美开始。这就是最初我收集到的，
took you from Austria to brought you here to America and then you got into films and you were as successful as anybody could ever imagine being in in films. You're the biggest star in the world and then you got into politics and became the 38th governor of California. So cool. It's it is amazing. And I ask people
把你从奥地利带到了美国，然后你进入了电影界，你在电影界取得了任何人能想象到的成功。你是世界上最伟大的明星，然后你进入了政界，成为了加利福尼亚州的第38任州长。太酷了。这真是太神奇了。我问人们
this sometimes when we've had musicians on an artist on on, just from every sort of whatever, whatever you do. And I always say, do you ever, do you have those moments where you sit back now and you go, wow, you look back where you came from, back from being a teen or being a kid in Austria. And now here you are having had this incredible run in all these different disciplines.
这个有时当我们有音乐家在艺术家在，只是从各种各样的无论，无论你做什么。我总是说，你有没有那些时刻，你现在坐下来，你说，哇，你回顾你来自哪里，从十几岁或在奥地利作为一个孩子。现在你在这里，在所有这些不同的学科中有了这段不可思议的经历。
And do you look back and go, hey, I really accomplished a lot. Are you able to enjoy it or have perspective of it in that way? I do sometimes, but very, very rare. First of all, because I never really feel that, you know, I am that great. By any means, I always felt like I could do better.
你回顾过去说，嘿，我真的完成了很多。你能够享受它或以那种方式看待它吗？我有时会，但非常非常罕见。首先，因为我从来没有真正觉得，你知道，我那么伟大。无论如何，我总是觉得我可以做得更好。
Even when I was in my body, but in heyday, I will win the Mistolumbia contest, and then I will look in the mirror afterwards and just say to myself, how the hell did this body win? It's kind of like a nut ever satisfied. I always want to climb higher and higher and higher. And I think that's what inspires me. But the thing that I do think about quite frequently is not that I did it, but how did I do it?
即使当我在我的身体里，但在全盛时期，我会赢得奥林匹亚先生比赛，然后我会在事后照镜子，只是对自己说，这个身体到底是怎么赢的？这有点像永远不满足。我总是想爬得更高更高更高。我认为这就是激励我的东西。但我经常想的事情不是我做到了，而是我是怎么做到的？
Right. Because that's a really interesting thing because how did you do it? Well, it's that the principles and this is I think why and I wrote this book be useful is because the principles and the tools that they used in bodybuilding, I used the very same tools in show business and they used the very same tools when I ran for governor and then to become governor and then to be governor. So it was the same thing. It was like having a great vision
对。因为那是一件非常有趣的事情，因为你是怎么做到的？好吧，这就是原则，我认为这就是为什么，我写了这本书《Be Useful》，因为原则和工具，他们在健美中使用的，我在演艺界使用了同样的工具，当我竞选州长然后成为州长然后担任州长时，我使用了同样的工具。所以是一样的。就像有一个伟大的愿景
and just chasing that vision, go after it relentlessly and to work your ass off, don't listen to the naysayers, you know, just shoot for a higher course rather than no course and just go all out, you know, because this is German saying, venture on tension and talk about it in the book. So if you do something, just, and talk about it in the book. So if you do something, just go all the way. And give something back, because you mentioned that briefly,
只是追逐那个愿景，无情地追求它，努力工作，不要听那些反对者的话，你知道，只是瞄准更高的目标而不是没有目标，只是全力以赴，你知道，因为这是德语说的，冒险紧张，在书中谈论它。所以如果你做某事，只是，在书中谈论它。所以如果你做某事，只是全力以赴。并回馈一些东西，因为你简要地提到了，
that I never felt that I was a self-made man, that I was very fortunate that I had so much help along the way, that I felt that I have to give something back now too. And so, you know, for decades now, I have been trying to give something back to my community with working with Special Olympics and being a coach for Special Olympics or starting after school programs or being the chairman of the President's Council on Physical Fitness and Sports of the President's Bush. And all of this was all about giving back, and then eventually becoming governor,
我从来没有觉得我是一个白手起家的人，我很幸运，我在这一路上得到了很多帮助，我觉得我现在也必须回馈一些东西。所以，你知道，几十年来，我一直试图通过与特奥会合作并担任特奥会教练，或者开始课后项目，或者担任布什总统的总统身体健康和体育委员会主席，来回馈我的社区。所有这些都是关于回馈，然后最终成为州长，
because remember when I ran for governor, my agents kept saying to me, I don't know, this is the stupidest move that I've ever seen, because I mean, you make two million dollars to move in. I mean, it's like, you know, what the hell, you're gonna miss out on two movies a year that's $40 million, why would you do that?
因为记得当我竞选州长时，我的经纪人一直对我说，我不知道，这是我见过的最愚蠢的举动，因为我是说，你拍一部电影赚两百万美元。我是说，这就像，你知道，搞什么，你会错过一年两部电影，那是4000万美元，你为什么要那样做？
And I said to myself, and I said to them, I say, hey, I made all the money because of America. I became what I am today because of America. I say America gave me the opportunity. So I don't mind putting now something back into it and giving something back. So that's the way I felt. But the key thing is, is the tools, there's tools that can make a success for. And I think I write about that very effectively in the book, and it's been really great to see the book be successful and be number one on the best solo list and all of those kind of things and selling really well internationally.
我对自己说，我对他们说，我说，嘿，我赚的所有钱都是因为美国。我成为今天的我都是因为美国。我说美国给了我机会。所以我现在不介意回馈一些东西，回馈一些东西。这就是我的感觉。但关键是，工具，有可以让你成功的工具。我认为我在书中非常有效地写了这一点，看到这本书取得成功并成为畅销书榜第一名以及所有这些事情，并且在国际上卖得非常好，这真的很棒。
Yeah, I watched your documentary. I thought it was incredibly inspiring, and I loved that it was in three parts. It was from Austria to bodybuilding then to being an actor, then to being the governor. And one of the things you said at the beginning of the documentary, which has stayed with me was, for you said, the whole thing started out with, yeah, I don't know why, but I was given this thing that was put in my head where, if I have a vision, I can't stop until I see it through.
是的，我看了你的纪录片。我觉得它非常鼓舞人心，我喜欢它是分三部分的。它是从奥地利到健美，然后到成为演员，再到成为州长。你在纪录片开头说的一件事，一直留在我的脑海里，你说，对你来说，整个事情开始于，是的，我不知道为什么，但我被赋予了这种东西，它被放在我的脑子里，如果我有一个愿景，我不能停止，直到我看到它实现。
I don't know why, you said, I don't know why I'm like that. I just am that. And you put on why I'm, you said I don't know why I'm like that. I just am that. And you put on your wall, a picture of your favorite body builder, your inspiration. And then you kept using like vision boards and then goal lists and everything. I've been talking about that for years.
我不知道为什么，你说，我不知道为什么我会那样。我就是那样。你在墙上贴了一张你最喜欢的健美运动员的照片，你的灵感。然后你一直使用像愿景板和目标清单之类的东西。我已经谈论那个很多年了。
So I really connected with that. I thought it was cool. Well, thank you very much. And then it is so true that if you have a vision it's so much easier to get kind of like into it and to kind of chase it rather than let's say going to the gym and not knowing why you're at the gym other than the doctor told you you should be a little bit because it's good for your health. But you know to me I always had fun going to the gym lifting the weights, doing a next day. I was looking forward to a next to a thousand set of sit-ups and stuff like that because I knew that each one of those reps
所以我真的和那个产生了共鸣。我觉得这很酷。好吧，非常感谢。而且确实，如果你有一个愿景，进入它并追逐它要容易得多，而不是说去健身房，不知道为什么你在健身房，除了医生告诉你你应该有一点，因为它对你的健康有好处。但你知道对我来说，我总是喜欢去健身房举重，做下一件事。我期待着下一千组仰卧起坐之类的东西，因为我知道每一个那些次数
is going to get me one step closer and winning that title. And you know, I admire this guy, Reg Park, who was Mr. Universe three times and then got into movies, into Hercules movies. And so I said to myself, well, I can do that. That's what I want to chase. That is the dream that I have, that's the division that I have. And that's what I'm trying to do. And then what you're mind was set on it, you're like, I'm getting that.
会让我离赢得那个冠军更近一步。而且你知道，我很钦佩这个家伙，雷格·帕克，他三次获得宇宙先生，然后进入电影，进入赫拉克勒斯电影。所以我对自己说，好吧，我可以做到。这就是我想追逐的。这就是我拥有的梦想，这就是我拥有的愿景。这就是我正在尝试做的。然后当你的心定下来时，你就像，我一定要得到那个。
It was like a machine. I was just following it and just trying to figure out, okay, how do I train now? And I copied this guy's training methods and other people's training methods. And it just, you know, it just, but the time I was 20, I became the youngest Mr. Universe ever.
它就像一台机器。我只是跟着它，试图弄清楚，好吧，我现在怎么训练？我复制了这个家伙的训练方法和其他人的训练方法。它只是，你知道，它只是，到我20岁时，我成为了有史以来最年轻的宇宙先生。
And so I realized that it was that, that having that dream that really helped me and not listening to me, they say it's because you can imagine you're 15 years old and you say to your parents, how long do we miss the universe? Right. You of course they're gonna say, well, you seek my child. Let's go to the doctor.
所以我意识到，正是那个，拥有那个梦想确实帮助了我，而不是听那些反对者的话，因为你可以想象你15岁，你对你的父母说，我们多久错过宇宙。对。你当然他们会说，好吧，你生病了我的孩子。让我们去看医生。
Right. So, they didn't believe in that dream at all, nor did anyone else as far as that goes because there was no one in Austria. Bodybuilding was an American sport. So, there was no one in Austria that ever won any competition, any kind of a Mr. Europe or Mr. Universe. So, how did you start actually bodybuilding in your 10, in the small town that you grew up?
对。所以，他们根本不相信那个梦想，就此而言也没有其他人相信，因为奥地利没有人。健美是一项美国运动。所以，奥地利没有人赢得过任何比赛，任何一种欧洲先生或宇宙先生。所以，你是怎么在你长大的小镇开始真正健美的？
Like, if nobody else was doing it, how did you even think of it as a possibility where you just extra strong as a kid and like it just came to you naturally? Like, no, I met a guy that was actually Mr. University, Mr. Austria. He was a bodybuilder. There was a lake where I grew up
就像，如果没人做，你怎么会想到它是一种可能性，你是小时候特别强壮，还是它自然而然地来到你身边？就像，不，我遇到了一个实际上是宇宙先生，奥地利先生的人。他是一个健美运动员。我长大的地方有一个湖
and he came down to that lake. So that's where I grew up and he came down to that lake. So that's where I met him and he brought me to that weightlifting gym. It was not a bodybuilding gym, it was a weightlifting gym. So I became part of the weightlifting team as a member of a year after working out. They made me be part of it. And then we started competing against other towns and villages in weightlifting competition. And so that was the main thing we did was lifting heavy weights and the Olympic lifting and then at the same time I used the time to do chin ups and to do some you know curls and some body parts to build my body also at the same time.
他来到那个湖边。所以这就是我长大的地方，他来到那个湖边。所以这就是我遇见他的地方，他带我去了那个举重健身房。那不是一个健美健身房，那是一个举重健身房。所以我成为了举重队的一员，锻炼一年后。他们让我成为它的一部分。然后我们开始在举重比赛中与其他城镇和村庄竞争。所以我们做的主要事情是举重和奥林匹克举重，同时我利用时间做引体向上和做一些你知道弯举和一些身体部位来锻炼我的身体，同时也。
So better was doing weightlifting, powerlifting and bodybuilding at the same time. So better was doing weightlifting, powerlifting and bodybuilding at the same time. So this is our... But the equipment was very crude, it was very simple. Only when I moved to Munich with the age of 19, I had a really well equipped gym there, and that's when I really started exploding. I mean, my body started growing really fast. Sean, you met a well equipped gym the other, right right a couple years ago. Yeah, we didn't go. It was his name James, but he went by Jim. Jimmy, Jimmy's name. He was well-equipped.
所以更好的是同时做举重、力量举重和健美。所以更好的是同时做举重、力量举重和健美。所以这是我们的……但设备非常粗糙，非常简单。只有当我19岁搬到慕尼黑时，我才在那里有一个设备齐全的健身房，那时我才真正开始爆发。我是说，我的身体开始长得非常快。肖恩，你几年前见过一个设备齐全的健身房，对吧？是的，我们没去。他叫詹姆斯，但他叫吉姆。吉米，吉米的名字。他设备齐全。
Let me ask you, Arnold, did you? Did you? I want to say, I was thinking about all the films that you've done. I was thinking about all the iconic roles, but certainly, and how much we get, we get, and people in people, like we'll stop, and people who are fans of stuff will stop you
让我问你，阿诺德，你吗？你吗？我想说，我一直在想你拍过的所有电影。我一直在想所有标志性的角色，但当然，以及我们得到了多少，我们得到了，人们在人们中，像我们会停下来，人们是东西的粉丝会拦住你
and say like something from your movie. And I think about how many times over the years, I've personally said, or heard people say the expression, I'll be back. I can't imagine how many times you've been at a restaurant, or somewhere where somebody has gone like, you've gone like, hey, can I get a cup of coffee and they're sure? And they look back and they go, I'll be back.
然后说一些你电影里的台词。我回想这些年来，我个人说了多少次，或者听别人说了多少次“我会回来的”（I'll be back）这句台词。我无法想象你到底在餐馆或其他什么地方遇到过多少次这种情况，有人会对你说，比如，嘿，能给我杯咖啡吗？他们会说“当然”，然后转过身去说“我会回来的”。
And like, I mean, it must have happened a million times, right? Yeah. Well, it's really wild because I go sometimes to an event. And people will be screaming out, get to the chopper. Yeah. Which is a line from Predator. Yeah. Or put the cook it down.
我的意思是，这一定发生过一百万次，对吧？是的。这真的很疯狂，因为有时我去参加活动，人们会大喊“去直升机那儿！”（Get to the chopper!）。是的，那是《铁血战士》里的台词。或者“把饼干放下”（Put the cookie down）。
Yeah. You know, it's lines from the movies, just wild, I mean, but you're right. It's funny hearing you do you. Wait, put the cookie down. Well, what was put the cookie down? You know, it was from Jingle all the way. So, it's a people repeat those lines.
是的。你知道，这些都是电影里的台词，太疯狂了。我是说，你是对的。听你这么说真有趣。等等，“把饼干放下”？那是哪部电影里的？那是《一路响叮当》（Jingle All the Way）里的。所以，人们会重复这些台词。
The funny thing is when you read it in the script, it doesn't read like anything like a special line, it's a, but just because the way I say it, you know, get to the chopper. So then the director comes and he says, it's not chopper, Arnold. It's chopper. It doesn't earn any. I said, no, get to the chopper. You know, I say everything wrong.
有趣的是，当你读剧本时，它看起来并不像什么特别的台词，但仅仅因为我说话的方式，你知道，“去直升机那儿”。然后导演过来跟我说：“阿诺，不是‘Chopper’，是‘Chopper’（发音纠正）。”我说：“不，就是‘Get to the chopper’。”你知道，我把所有词都说错了。
It's a people think that's funny. And then they repeat the lines. But your accent is just so beautiful. It's just so iconic, and I'm so glad that it has stayed, that it has been like beat now to you by living in Southern California too long. You know, I could listen to you all day. What's that? You ran, you've run so many things at such a high level sets, our state.
人们觉得这很有趣，然后他们就重复这些台词。但你的口音真的很美，非常经典，我很高兴它保留了下来，没有因为在南加州住得太久而消失。你知道，我可以听你讲一整天。怎么说呢？你在如此高的层面上经营过这么多事情，我们的州。
What are you enjoying pointing all of those incredible leadership skills at now that some people may know about, some people might not know about, but obviously your skill set is huge. Are you enjoying pointing it out something right now? or are you enjoying letting it rest for a minute? No, no, I mean, look, I was very fortunate to be involved in all those different careers. And I learned so much in bodybuilding and how to be competitive and all that.
现在你正享受着将那些不可思议的领导才能运用到什么地方呢？有些人可能知道，有些人可能不知道，但显然你的技能储备非常庞大。你现在正享受着运用这些技能吗？还是你正享受着休息一会儿？不，不，你看，我非常幸运能参与所有这些不同的职业。我在健美运动中学到了很多，学会了如何去竞争，诸如此类。
I learned so much in show business. It has just been a most extraordinary ride to work on orders, movies and to work with such great directors and then to go into politics and to get into becoming governor of the state of California and to sit at the capital and to learn every day something new. I mean, it's absolutely, if they imagine that when you go in there as an actor, I mean, I've never done policy. I've never got needed the details and minute details of policy. But now you're sitting there and now you're sitting, you have meetings from nine o'clock on in the morning and you sit down and always say, the nurses union comes in. And you talk about the four to one ratio versus a six to one ratio.
我在演艺圈也学到了很多。能参与那些电影，与如此伟大的导演合作，然后进入政界，成为加利福尼亚州州长，坐在首府，每天学习新东西，这真是一段非凡的旅程。我的意思是，如果你以演员的身份进入那里，你绝对无法想象。我从未处理过政策，我从未深入了解过政策的细枝末节。但现在你坐在那里，从早上九点开始开会，你坐下来，护士工会进来了，你们讨论四比一的比例与六比一的比例。
And you say to yourself, what are they? What are they talking about? Yeah. You don't even know. Right. And so, so then afterwards you have to have the briefings and all that stuff so you can come back and then continue that meeting later on. And then the prison got union will come in and they will talk about their problems.
你对自己说，他们在说什么？他们在谈论什么？是的。你甚至都不知道。对吧。所以，之后你必须进行简报等等，这样你才能回来，然后在稍后继续那个会议。然后监狱工会会进来，他们会谈论他们的问题。
Then the teachers' union comes in and talks about their problem. Then health care advocates come in and order for come in. Indian gaming drives come in and they talk about their issues and stuff. So it's like, it's literally like I said, it's a university, the capital. And I have learned stuff there in the seven years that you would never learn in any university. No way. And they teach you that, you know, how to craft all of the... Anybody listening should try to be a governor right now.
然后教师工会进来谈论他们的问题。然后医疗保健倡导者进来，然后是其他组织。印第安博彩部落进来谈论他们的问题等等。所以这就像我说的，首府就是一所大学。我在那七年里学到的东西，你在任何大学里都学不到。绝对学不到。他们教你如何制定所有的……任何听众现在都应该尝试去当州长。
Yeah, I mean, I tell you, it's quite a challenge. It was the most pleasurable thing to serve 40 million people and to be in charge of the fifth largest economy in the world. I mean, it was really extraordinary and it wasn't easy. It was very, very tough. It was very tough on my family also because you promise to your family that you are the most important thing, but then when you become governor, then you promise to the California people that they're the most important thing.
是的，我的意思是，我告诉你，这确实是一个挑战。为四千万人民服务，掌管世界第五大经济体，这是最令人愉快的事情。我的意思是，这真的很非凡，而且并不容易。这非常非常艰难。这对我的家庭也很艰难，因为你向家人承诺他们是最重要的，但当你成为州长后，你又向加州人民承诺他们是最重要的。
Right. That clashes sometimes. So I would go and I would go to fundraises at night. I would be having meetings all day and I would not be around for those recitals and for the sports competitions that my kids had. And so the times when I came home and my kids would be sitting on the table where I'm sitting right now and then then we would start crying. Daddy, why won't you not at my football game?
对。这有时会发生冲突。所以我晚上会去参加筹款活动。我整天都在开会，我无法参加孩子们参加的独奏会和体育比赛。所以当我回到家，孩子们坐在我现在坐的这张桌子旁，然后我们就会开始哭。爸爸，你为什么没去我的足球比赛？
But Daddy, why didn't you watch me, on Thursday when I was practicing soccer, and all of this kind of thing, then one after the next started crying. And I remember my wife, Maria was sitting there, she says, okay, kids, just express yourself now. Now it's the time to express yourself. I said, no, that's the last thing I'll tell you.
但爸爸，为什么周四我练习足球时你没来看我？诸如此类的事情，然后一个接一个地开始哭。我记得我的妻子玛丽亚坐在那里，她说：“好了，孩子们，现在表达你们的感受吧。现在是表达你们感受的时候了。”我说：“不，那是我最后想听到的。”
Wait, so anyway, so we have good wild scenes. So it's very tough to do those kind of things, but I tell you, I wouldn't exchange it for anything. I'm curious about, Arnold, you keep talking about coming here to America. I did too. I only drove 90 minutes to Buffalo from Toronto, but I, I only drove 90 minutes to Buffalo from Toronto, but I was wondering about when you first got here, when you first came to California, where did Arnold, like, where did you write on your landing car? Where did you stay? Did you have an apartment?
等等，总之，我们有很多疯狂的场景。所以做这些事情非常艰难，但我告诉你，我什么都不会换。阿诺，我很好奇，你一直谈论来到美国。我也一样。我只是从多伦多开车90分钟到了布法罗，但我一直在想，当你第一次来到这里，当你第一次来到加州时，阿诺，你落地时写了什么？你住在哪里？你有公寓吗？
Did you know somebody? Did you move into a hotel? Like literally, what was the granular, like, what was that day like? When you land and you went through customs and they're like, what are you doing here? And you're like, I'm gonna be bodybuilder and then I'm gonna be a movie star and then I'm gonna be governor, look out. And like, how did that day go?
你认识什么人吗？你搬进酒店了吗？字面上讲，那一天是什么样的？当你落地，通过海关，他们问你来这里做什么？你说：“我要成为健美运动员，然后我要成为电影明星，然后我要成为州长，等着瞧。”那一天是怎么过的？
So I was Mr. Universe. I just wanted to Mr. Universe competition in Ken for the second time at the age of 21. And this guy by the name of Joe Weeda, who was then kind of the Zah of bodybuilding. He was the publisher of the bodybuilding magazines in the years of weight distribution, kind of an equipment distribution company, food supplement company, and he brought me to the United States.
当时我是“宇宙先生”。我在21岁时第二次赢得了在肯尼亚举办的“宇宙先生”比赛。有个叫乔·韦德（Joe Weider）的人，他当时算是健美界的沙皇。他是健美杂志的出版商，拥有重量分销公司、设备分销公司、食品补充剂公司，他把我带到了美国。
And so he sent me out to Los Angeles because this is where the best gymnasiums were. And he asked some of his friends, look, why don't you go and find an apartment for honor and then mean them let him stay there at your house. And so I stayed at someone's house for three days. Then in the meantime, they found an apartment for me in North Hollywood. And there I started training then at Vince's gym which was one of the great bodybuilding gyms where a lot of the champions trained. And then eventually I moved over to the Sanamonica, the Venice where Gord's gym
所以他把我派到了洛杉矶，因为那里有最好的健身房。他问他的一些朋友：“嘿，你们为什么不去给阿诺找个公寓，然后让他住在你们家？”所以我先在某人家里住了三天。同时，他们在北好莱坞为我找了一间公寓。我在那里开始在文斯健身房（Vince's Gym）训练，那是许多冠军训练的伟大健美健身房之一。后来我搬到了圣莫尼卡，威尼斯，那里有黄金健身房（Gold's Gym）。
was and then I started training there. What was your English light? What was your English light at that time? Oh it sucked. It totally sucked. I mean, it was like in a school English, I was a few times in England for both posing exhibitions and strong men acts and stuff like that. So I was able to practice a little bit the English, but I couldn't read a newspaper. I couldn't really understand television.
然后我就在那里开始训练了。你当时的英语怎么样？哦，糟透了。完全糟透了。我的意思是，就像学校里的英语，我去过几次英国参加造型表演和大力士表演之类的。所以我能练习一点英语，但我读不懂报纸。我真的听不懂电视。
I had a friend, a Jewish friend that spoke German, but the name of Ari Zeller, who was a bodybuilding photographer, and he would translate for me when we watched the news. And I remember when there were discussions in press conferences with Nixon, many ran for president and to Humphrey. And he would always translate. And he was a real liberal, this guy.
我有一个会说德语的犹太朋友，名叫阿里·泽勒（Ari Zeller），他是一位健美摄影师，我们看新闻时他会为我翻译。我记得当时尼克松竞选总统和汉弗莱竞选时，新闻发布会上有很多讨论。他总是会翻译。这家伙是个真正的自由派。
And when I said, I like what Nixon said, he says, I don't be absurd, I don't know. This is absurd. He's a fool. Don't even listen to him. So he would always get mad at me about that. But in any case, so I could not really understand. I was not with the program at all.
当我说“我喜欢尼克松说的话”时，他说：“别荒谬了，阿诺。这太荒谬了。他是个傻瓜。别听他的。”所以他总是因为这个对我生气。但无论如何，我真的听不懂。我完全跟不上节奏。
But one thing I remembered, and that was, it was now Thanksgiving. And it was, I did not know what Thanksgiving was. And the guy came over to me in the gym and he says, what are you doing Thanksgiving? And I said, what is Thanksgiving? He says, well, it's a special holiday. And all this, he says, well, we eat a lot of food. He says, if you don't have anything to do,
但我记得一件事，那是感恩节。我不知道感恩节是什么。健身房里有个家伙走过来问我：“感恩节你打算做什么？”我说：“感恩节是什么？”他说：“哦，这是一个特殊的节日。我们吃很多食物。如果你没什么事做，”
if you don't have anyone to spend the day with, I want to invite you to my house and so this guy built Drake invited me to his house and there it is unbelievable Thanksgiving dinner the first Thanksgiving dinner the following day when the word got around the gym that I was new and that was kind of helpless here and and all that they came over to my apartment and they brought dishes, they brought silverware, pillowcases, pillows, and all kinds of, even a black and white TV. One guy gave me the old antenna like it used to be. And then a little radio, a wooden box, the radio for my nightstand on the side of the bed. So I mean, the generosity that I experienced was so staggering and so touching.
“如果你没有人和你一起过节，我想邀请你去我家。”所以这个叫比尔·德雷克（Bill Drake）的家伙邀请我去了他家，那是一顿令人难以置信的感恩节晚餐。第二天，当健身房里传出我是新人，在这里有点无助的消息时，他们来到我的公寓，带来了盘子、餐具、枕套、枕头，还有各种东西，甚至还有一台黑白电视机。一个人给了我旧天线，就像以前那种。还有一个小收音机，一个木盒子，放在我床头的床头柜上。所以，我所经历的慷慨是如此令人震惊和感动。
I would never forget that this is why today, I was away at the Hollandbeck Center. You know, for the 30 second time, in the sense I've been in America, to give out Turkey, because I donate to Turkey for the poor people in East LA and So we handed out hundreds of turkeys to this poor people that sometimes can't even afford to have a nice turkey dinner Just because I remember that day how this guy included me
我永远不会忘记这一点，这就是为什么今天，我去了霍伦贝克中心（Hollenbeck Center）。你知道，这是我来美国的第32次，去分发火鸡，因为我为东洛杉矶的穷人捐赠火鸡。所以我们向那些有时甚至买不起一顿丰盛火鸡晚餐的穷人分发了数百只火鸡。仅仅是因为我记得那天那个家伙是如何接纳我的。
So I always wanted to do the same thing back to the American people to put people to people that needed. That's great. We'll be right back. Hey smartless listener, let's talk about a destination that defines paradise. Naples, Marco Island, and the Everglades, Florida's Paradise Coast. In vision over 30 miles of pristine Gulf Shoreline ranging from secluded Keywaden Island to luxury beachfront resorts, perfect for every beach lover, whether you're playing in the surf, soaking up the
所以我一直想以同样的方式回馈美国人民，回馈那些需要帮助的人。太棒了。我们马上回来。嘿，Smartless的听众，让我们聊聊一个定义了天堂的目的地。那不勒斯、马可岛和大沼泽地，佛罗里达的天堂海岸。想象一下超过30英里的原始墨西哥湾海岸线，从隐秘的基瓦登岛到豪华的海滨度假村，这里是每一位海滩爱好者的天堂，无论你是在冲浪、享受阳光，
sun, or enjoying a gorgeous sunset, this destination offers it all. Explore the natural wonders of Florida's paradise coast featuring mangroves. Mangroves? I'm in. Estuaries and a plethora of outdoor adventurers from guided swamp walks and kayaking to boating, fishing diving, and championship golf courses, this paradise caters to diverse interests. Seeking luxury, Naples delivers with high-end shopping
还是欣赏绚丽的日落，这个目的地应有尽有。探索佛罗里达天堂海岸的自然奇观，包括红树林。红树林？我加入。河口和众多的户外探险活动，从有向导的沼泽漫步和皮划艇到划船、钓鱼、潜水和锦标赛级高尔夫球场，这个天堂满足了各种兴趣。追求奢华？那不勒斯通过高端购物来满足你，
at Fifth Avenue South and Mercado. Rejuvenate amid ciprus trees and golf breezes at world-class spots and indulgent co-stair services for a truly luxurious experience. Culinary delights await with fresh from the golf seafood, sustainable stone crab season from October to May, and exclusive chef's table encounters. Don't just listen, experience it.
在第五大道南和梅尔卡多。在柏树和海风中通过世界级的温泉和放纵的护理服务恢复活力，获得真正奢华的体验。烹饪美食等待着你，有来自墨西哥湾的新鲜海鲜、10月至5月的可持续石蟹季节，以及独家的主厨餐桌体验。不要只听，去体验吧。
For the finest of everything Florida has to offer, only Paradise will do. Plan your trip today at ParadiseCost.com slash Smartless. Smartless is supported by Hydro. So for me time is is everything, right? We're all scrunched for time. We have things, we have families, we have work, we have whatever, everything. So I'm looking for a fast workout that I know works.
为了佛罗里达所能提供的最美好的一切，只有天堂才够。今天就在ParadiseCoast.com/Smartless规划你的旅行吧。Smartless由Hydro支持。所以对我来说，时间就是一切，对吧？我们都时间紧迫。我们有事情，有家庭，有工作，有各种各样的事情。所以我正在寻找一种我知道有效的快速锻炼方式。
And with Hydro in 20 minutes, it's a better use of my time to get a full body workout, which is what I've been looking for. Hydro is the best. It's a state-of-the-art at-home, rowing machine designed by rowers that delivers the ultimate full body workout. How ultimate? It works 86% of your muscles. I'm talking arms, legs, core,
有了Hydro，20分钟内，这是我利用时间进行全身锻炼的更好方式，这正是我一直在寻找的。Hydro是最好的。它是一台由划船运动员设计的、最先进的家用划船机，能提供终极的全身锻炼。有多终极？它能锻炼你86%的肌肉。我说的是手臂、腿部、核心，
and it only takes 20 minutes. I'm in, right? Rowing with Hydro is low impact, so low risk of injury. The workouts are taught by Olympians and world-class athletes who are great coaches for any fitness level. Okay, so I literally just got mine delivered, so I'm getting started.
而且只需要20分钟。我加入，对吧？用Hydro划船是低冲击的，所以受伤风险很低。锻炼课程由奥运选手和世界级运动员教授，他们是适合任何健身水平的伟大教练。好吧，所以我刚收到我的机器，所以我正准备开始。
But I love it because it's in my home. I love the great programs and the videos, but I like it because it actually makes me feel like I'm accomplishing something. You know what I mean? I actually feel like I'm rowing somewhere and I can't wait to get there. And also when someone comes by my house, I show it to them and they're like, ooh, how do I get one? Join the growing, growing community at Hydro and make sure you let them know Smartless sent you. Head over to Hydro.com and use Code Smartless to save up to $500 off your Hydro.
但我喜欢它，因为它在我的家里。我喜欢那些很棒的程序和视频，但我喜欢它是因为它真的让我觉得我完成了一些事情。你知道我的意思吗？我真的觉得我在划向某个地方，我迫不及待地想到达那里。而且当有人来我家时，我向他们展示，他们会说：“噢，我怎么才能买到一个？”加入Hydro不断增长的社区，确保让他们知道是Smartless推荐你来的。前往Hydro.com并使用代码Smartless，最高可节省500美元。
That's h-y-d-r-o-w.com. Code Smartless to save up to Audible for their support. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. There's an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from best sellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and more. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog of thousands of titles. I'm currently listening to my friend Tina Fey's book Bossy Pants. I love Tina, she's a friend, and what's great about it, she's narrating it. It's so funny, I read it a long time ago, but I'm listening to it again, it's so good.
那是h-y-d-r-o-w.com。代码Smartless以节省……感谢Audible的支持。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有的音频娱乐。你总能找到你所爱的最好的内容或发现新的东西。这里有令人难以置信的有声读物选择，涵盖各种类型，从畅销书和新书到名人回忆录、悬疑和惊悚、励志、健康、商业等等。作为Audible会员，你可以每月选择一本有声书保留，从他们成千上万本的目录中选择。我目前正在听我朋友蒂娜·菲（Tina Fey）的书《Bossy Pants》。我爱蒂娜，她是我的朋友，最棒的是，她亲自朗读。这太有趣了，我很久以前读过，但我正在再听一遍，太棒了。
New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Well, with such meager beginnings, I mean, the leap from there to thinking that you could actually be the governor of the state, when do you remember the first time you thought, well, maybe that's something I could do. Was it during Reagan's administration, you thought, well, hang on, here's an actor who
新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless到500-500。那是audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless到500-500以免费试用Audible 30天。一定要访问我们的网址，让他们知道是我们推荐的，audible.com/smartless。现在回到节目。好吧，起点如此微薄，我的意思是，从那里跨越到认为你真的可以成为州长，你还记得第一次想到“也许那是我能做的事”是什么时候吗？是在里根政府时期吗？你想到“等等，这里有一个演员成为了州长，而我是一个演员，所以我为什么不能呢？”那是第一次觉得可行性的联系吗？不，并不是，因为我知道当时有关于外来者进入的故事。有关于艾森豪威尔的故事，他是一名将军，根本不是政治家，我可以在美国展示。有篮球运动员。约翰·格伦最终成为了参议员，他是一名宇航员。所以，尽管看到来自娱乐界的人（因为每个人总是嘲笑这一点，他们来自好莱坞，怎么可能有人成为州长，
became a governor, and I'm an actor, so why can't I get it? Was that the linkage that was the first time it felt plausible? No, not really, because I knew at that time there was stories written that people from the outside come in. There was stories about Eisenhower, who was a general, who was not a politician at all, and I can present it in the United States. There were people that were basketball players. John Glendon eventually became a senator, he was an astronaut, norris. So that was not even though it was great to see that someone from entertainment, because everyone always laughed at that, they were from Hollywood, how can anyone become governor,
当他来自好莱坞时，或者如果你来自好莱坞，一个演员，怎么可能成为总统）是很棒的。所以当然有那种对话，但我认为真正激励我的是，也许有一点点那个，但也像我说的，和施赖弗家族、肯尼迪家族在一起，然后成为总统身体素质和体育委员会的主席，
when he's from Hollywood, or how can he become president, if you're from Hollywood, an act and stuff like that. So there were those kind of conversations, of course, but I think what really inspired me was, maybe a little bit of that, but also, like I said, hanging out with the Shrivers, with the Kennedys, then becoming the chairman of the president's council and physical fitness and sports
在老布什总统手下，1990年。他让我担任主席。所以当我和他在一起时，他邀请我去了戴维营，我的意思是，很多次。所以我真的花了很多时间和他在那里，我们组织了一场伟大的美国锻炼，他参加了几次会议。我在戴维营和白宫。所以所有这些真的激励了我，我说，我只是……能像他那样把人们聚集在一起，让这里成为一个更好的地方、一个更好的国家、一个更好的州，或者其他什么，这是一项多么美妙的工作。
on the president Bush Senior in 1990. He made me chairman. And so when I hung out with him and he invited me to camp David, I mean, so many times. So I really spend a lot of time with him and we organized a great American workout and that he had been sitting on several of the meetings. I up in camp David and also in the White House. And so all of that really inspired me, and I said, I'm just, there is such a wonderful job to bring people together like he does and to make this a better place, a better country, a better state, or whatever.
所以我受到了启发。仅仅是你和总统在一起的事实，它让你觉得，好吧，我知道这家伙是一个人类。他是一个和我一样的人。我相信这消除了一些那种令人衰弱的神秘感。
So I got inspired with that. And just the mere fact that you were hanging out with somebody who was president, it sort of made it feel like, well, I know this guy's a human being. He's a man just like me. It's sort of, I'm sure it took care of some of the sort of debilitating mystique that's.
让它变得稍微正常了一些。是的。而且他总是给我的赞美是，你知道，你甚至对这些东西、对权力、对精确的自负、对所有这些东西的兴趣都有很好的直觉。但我当时正处于电影生涯的中期。是的。
Made it through the right size a little bit. Yeah. And also the compliment that he always gave me is, you know, you are not even good nose for this stuff, for power, the exact conceit, the interest that it in all this stuff. But I was in the middle of my movie career then. Yeah.
这只是，你知道，第一次尝试你们这些家伙非常擅长的事情，那就是喜剧，你知道，因为我是一个动作英雄，我当时在拍《终结者》、《铁血战士》、《过关斩将》和《红场特警》，所有这些电影，它们的票房收入不断增加。但后来我有一种冲动，说：“我必须拍喜剧。”
It was just, you know, just preaching over for the first time, things that you guys are so good at, which is comedy, you know, because I was an action hero, I was doing Terminator and Predator and Running Man and Red Heat in all those movies, and they keep grossing more money. But then I had this urge to say, I gotta do comedy.
你当时非常搞笑。坚持拍动作片。然后每个人都说：“算了吧，我必须拍喜剧。”你当时非常搞笑。坚持拍动作片。然后每个人都说：“算了吧，那不会发生的。”但后来伊万·雷特曼（Ivan Reitman），他是《捉鬼敢死队》的制片人，我的意思是，导演，他对我说了，我做。我要为你开发一个项目。他确实做了。那是《龙兄鼠弟》（Twins）。
And you were a hilarious. It stuck here and doing action. And then everyone said, forget say, I got to do comedy. And you were hilarious. It stuck here and doing action. And then everyone said, forget it, it's not going to happen. But then Ivan Rybman, who was the producer, I mean, the director of Ghostbusters, he said to me, I do it. I'm going to develop a project for you. And he did. There was twin twins.
那是《龙兄鼠弟》。是的，所以我们在1988年做了那个。我们在1988年12月与布什总统在肯尼迪中心举行了总统首映式。电影大获成功。所以它实际上是第一部国内票房超过1亿美元的电影。所以它赚了一亿两千八百万美元。所以这确实是我感到兴奋的事情。所以我当时就像是在爬那座梯子，你知道，我只是爬到了珠穆朗玛峰的三分之二，我还有三分之一要爬，我觉得是这样。然后我拍了《终结者2》，所以我当时并没有真正处于那种说“好吧，我现在要竞选”的阶段。
It was twin twins. Yeah, and so we did that in 1988. We had with President Bush, a presidential premier at the Kennedy Center in 1988 in December. And the movie went through the roof. And so it was the first movie actually that made over $100 million domestically. So it was made a hundred and twenty eight million dollars. So it was really something that was I was excited about. So I was kind of like in the middle of climbing that ladder you know it was just two thirds up a mountain Everest and I still had to go climb one third more and I felt like it's so then I did terminated too and so that was I was not really at that stage where I said okay I'm gonna run now.
不，但应该指出的是，我只是想插一句，因为你对此非常谦虚。你想拍一部喜剧，以至于制片厂不确定，告诉我我理解得对不对，制片厂不确定你是否是一个如此有票房号召力的动作明星，或者他们不确定你是否能够开启一部喜剧。你对自己冒了险，这就是你一直以来的做法。你预付分文未取，你只是拿了百分比，你只是拿了票房的一大块。而《龙兄鼠弟》是你迄今为止最大的收入，因为它是一个巨大的成功。
No but I should it should be pointed out. I just want to sideburn, because you're being quite modest about it. You wanted to do a comedy, and to the point that the studio wasn't sure, tell me if I've got this right or wrong, the studio wasn't sure that you were such a bankable actionist or they weren't sure that you would be a bankable,
你对自己下了注，这太他妈棒了，因为你一生都在对自己下注，而且得到了回报。我说得对吗？你绝对是对的，研究得非常好，我必须说，你知道，所有的细节，我喜欢那个，但我的意思是，底线是制片厂，
you'd be able to open a comedy. And you took a risk on yourself, which is what you've been known to do. And you took nothing upfront, and you just took a percent, you just took a big piece of the box office. And twins was your biggest payday ever by far because it was such a massive hit.
不仅不相信它能开启一部喜剧电影，他们还对我说，他们对我说：“阿诺，现在告诉我，为什么我要去投资一部喜剧，当我们现在用你的动作电影赚这么多钱时？你以为我们很蠢吗？”正如我所说：“不，不，不，我完全理解。”所以我们必须想办法让它变得更
And you bet on yourself, which is so fucking great, because you've been betting on yourself your whole life and it paid off. Am I right about that? You're absolutely right, very well researched, I have to say, you know, all the details, I love that, but I mean, that the bottom line was the studio space,
吸引他们。所以伊万·雷特曼当时说的是，我们都应该做的是，我们应该以1650万美元的预算制作这部电影，并且不拿薪水。他说：“我不拿薪水，他不拿薪水，你也不拿薪水。”我们所做的是作为回报，我们一起获得40%的所有权。我们重新谈判，他们把它变成了37.5%，因为汤姆·波拉克（Tom Pollack）是伊万·雷特曼的好朋友，他觉得他从制片厂那里得到了压力来达成这笔交易。所以我们给了他2.5%的份额，我们拿了37.5%，但你绝对是对的。那为我赚的钱比任何东西都多，因为在全球范围内，这部电影的票房超过了……
not only didn't believe that it could open a movie in the comedy, but they also said to me, they said to me, I wrote, tell me now why I would go and invest in a comedy when we are making all this money now with your action movies. What do you think? We're stupid. And as I said, no, no, no, no, I totally understand it. So we had to figure out a way to kind of make it more
还有租赁收入。是的，你知道，有很多东西，我们从未把电影卖给航空公司，当他们把它卖给电视、网络和所有不同的渠道时，我现在还在拿剩余收益。那太神奇了。那太神奇了。这就是它的方式。
appealing to them. And so with Ivan Rythman then said was what we should all do is we should make the movie for 16 and a half million dollars and not take a salary He says I won't take a salary Then it doesn't take a salary and you don't take a salary, I don't. And what we do is in return, we go and get 40% ownership together. We renegotiated and we renegotiated and they made it 37.5% because Tom Pollack was a good friend of Ivan Ryattman and he felt kind of he got a beating from the studio to make the deal. So we gave him a 2.5% cut and we made 37 and half but you absolutely right. That made more money for me than anything because worldwide the movie crossed over $220,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000, and rentals too. Yeah, you know, it was, you know,
这很令人担忧。但无论如何，底线是我仍然在成长，我拍了《幼儿园特警》，之后是《魔鬼二世》和《真实的谎言》，那是卡梅隆的，所以它们都是喜剧和动作之类的东西。但你觉得你那个惹麻烦的女婿怎么样？这家伙是克里斯·帕拉特（Chris Pratt）。是的，帕拉特。
there was a lot of things that we've never sold the movie to the earplanes, when they sold it to the TV, to network, and to all the different, and I'm still getting residuals now. That's amazing. That's amazing. That's the way it's about.
我的意思是，这家伙，我们认识他，我们认识帕拉特。他是个小混混，他是个惹麻烦的人，他是个……他是个伟大的朋友。我们和他一起笑。我们和他一起笑。他非常推崇你。这让我有点嫉妒。听起来你们在那边有一种很好的家庭节奏，聚在一起吃晚餐、度假、闲逛。听起来真是一件好事。你是对的。我的意思是，这太有趣了。当他和我的女儿来到这里时，他们就像上周一样，在一个周六过来，
It's worrying about you. But I mean, anyway, the bottom line is that I was still, now I was like growing, I was doing kindergarten, cop after that, junior and true lies, which in Cameron, and so they were all kind of like comedies and action and all that stuff. But then what do you think about this troublemaker, son-in-law of yours? This fellow is Chris Pratt. Yeah, Pratt.
早上七点来帮我喂动物。早上七点来帮我喂动物。所以，你知道，当然我有一匹迷你马，我有一头迷你驴，我有一头猪，我有三只狗。我的意思是，到处都是动物。所以当然早上我总是喂它们。所以我告诉帕拉特，我说：“起床，把孩子们带过来。”你喂它们像迷你甜甜圈和迷你……
I mean, this guy, we know him, we know Pratt. He's a little, he's an outlaw, he's a troublemaker, he's a,blemaker. He's a great friend of ours. We laugh with them. We laugh with them. He talks very highly of you. It gets me a little jealous. It sounds like you guys have a great sort of family sort of rhythm going over there with getting together for dinners and vacations and hanging out It just sounds like a really good thing. You're right. I mean, it is so much fun When he and my daughter comes over here to the house and They come over like last week to come over one Saturday
它们吃迷你食物吗？还是你只是给它们较小的份量？不，不，只是较小的份量。有些不需要较小的份量。它们已经给猪较小的份量了。是的，现在有点麻烦。肖恩？一直都是。
It's seven in the morning to help me feed the animals It's seven in the morning to help me feed the animals. So, you know, which of course I have a miniature pony, I have a miniature donkey, I have a pig, I have three dogs. I mean, there's this animals all over the place. And so of course in the morning I always feed them. So I told the cat, and I said, get up and bring the kids over. Do you feed them like many donuts and many,
我的意思是，就像当你把它放出来时，它整天都在草地上吃草。然后它进厨房。它在厨房里看到的任何东西，它都吃掉。猪，等等，猪进厨房？是的，猪睡觉。它是家猪。家猪。
do they have many food? Or you just give them smaller portions? No, no, it's just a smaller portion. Some of them don't need smaller portions. They'll already give a smaller portion to a pig. Yeah, it's kind of a bitch now. Sean? All the time.
是的，是的，绝对。是的，是的，是的，这取决于你如何对待动物。但我的狗进屋，驴也进屋。得了吧。他进屋了。这就是他们的意思。是的。我明白了。
I mean, it's like when you let it out, it goes out in the grass and then it's grass all day long. There comes in the kitchen. And everything that he sees in the kitchen, the traps down. The pig, wait, the pig comes in the kitchen? Yeah, the pig sleeps. It's a house pig. The house pig.
迷你，但迷你，即使是一匹普通的马，我曾经带过，我有一头野牛。是什么？来到我的厨房，一头野牛。你知道，大野牛。哦，野牛？野牛，是的。我的意思是，所以我打开了这里的双开门，
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yeah, yeah, yeah, it depends what the way you deal with it, the animals. But my dogs come into the house, the donkey comes into the house. Come on. He comes into the house. This is what they're meaning. Yeah. I get it.
因为我们每年在这里举办扑克锦标赛，为课后项目筹集资金。去年十月我们筹集了700万美元。所以主题是慕尼黑啤酒节。每个人都必须穿皮裤，女人们穿紧身连衣裙之类的东西。作为娱乐的一部分，我让所有这些动物来到这里。所以我只是，我说，我们让这头野牛站在外面。所以我说，让我试一试，因为它在网上。当你上网时，你可以看到有一个农民从它还是个小宝宝的时候就养大了他的
The many, but the many, even if it's a regular horse, I wear every bring, brought, I had a pison. What is it? Coming to my kitchen here, a pison. You know, the big pison. Oh, pison? The pison, yeah. I mean, I mean, so I opened up the double door here
野牛，然后用奶瓶喂它牛奶之类的东西。然后它仍然来到他家厨房，农民不得不加宽门并增加门的高度。所以我试着做同样的事情。我打开门，把这头野牛带进厨房。我的意思是，如果这个混蛋发疯了，它会毁了整个房子，因为它太大了。但我的意思是，所以是的，我觉得当你把动物带进厨房
because we have every year year a poker tournament here to raise money for after-school programs. And this last October we raised $7 million with them. So the theme was October Fest. Everyone had to wear leather hoes and the women wear turundles and all that stuff. And I have, as part of the entertainment, I have all this animals coming over here. So they just, I said, we had this by standing outside. So I said, let me just try it because it's so it's on the online. When you go online, you can see there's a farmer that raised his
带进屋里，让它们四处走动时，这很酷。所以早些时候，我想那是杰森问的一个问题。当我正在……你知道，你爬上了实现健美伟大的那座山，你爬上了成为全球国际电影明星的那座巨大山峰。我们有史以来最大的电影明星。是的，有史以来。
bison from the time he was like a little baby and then fed it with the bottle and milk and all this stuff. And then he's still coming, he's still coming into the kitchen at his farmer's house here to widen the door and increase the height of the door. So I tried to do the same thing. I opened up the door and I brought this pie into the kitchen. I mean, if this side of a bitch would have gone crazy, would have destroyed the whole house because it was so big. But I mean, so yeah, I think it's cool when you bring animals into the kitchen
在阿诺之前没有人做到过那么大。对。然后你爬上了成为加州州长的第三座山。还有第四座山吗？还有另一个篇章吗？比如，你知道吗，还有一件事我真的很想做。我的目光锁定在……
and into the house and that they roam around. So earlier, I think it was a question Jason had. When I was going, you know, you climb this mountain of achieving this bodybuilding greatness, you climb this massive mountain of being a global international movie star. The biggest movie star we've ever had. Yeah, ever.
他正试图让你去演音乐剧。别上当。这很有趣，非常有趣。但我的意思是，你知道，有时候我们有一种我们追求的愿景，就像我在健美运动中所做的那样，就像我在演艺圈所做的那样。但我的愿景不是成为州长。只有后来，
Nobody had done it that big before Arnold. Right. And then you climbed this third mountain of being the governor of California. Is there a fourth mountain? Is there another chapter like, you know what, there's one more thing I really want to do. I have my eyes set on blank.
突然间，当我们进行罢免选举时，我突然对整个想法着迷了。是的。然后我竞选了州长。但我的意思是，现在我的愿景是，我想去帮助人们变得更成功。我不知何故进入了这些励志演讲，因为我开始在大学毕业典礼上发表励志演讲，然后突然间它变得疯狂，像野火一样蔓延，人们开始写信给我，问我为什么不写一本书之类的。所以我一直在世界各地进行励志演讲，有点像前总统们参加的演讲巡回赛，
He's trying to get you to musical theater. Just don't take the bait. That's funny, very funny. But I mean, you know, the thing, we sometimes kind of have a vision that we go after, like I did with bodybuilding, and like I did with show business. But my vision was not to become governor. Only later on,
你知道，你可以从中赚些钱，而且你可以接触到很多人。由此产生了这本书。所以这是我现在真正投入的新事物，那就是：我们如何帮助人们？因为有太多人不快乐。有太多人靠药物来获得快乐。
all of a sudden, when we had a recall, all of a sudden I kind of got obsessed with the whole idea. Yeah. And I ran for governor. But I mean, now my vision is kind of like, I want to go and help people become more successful. I somehow got into these motivational speeches because I started giving a motivation speech when a commencement speech at universities and then all of a sudden that kind of went wild, went to the spread like wildfire and people started writing to me, why don't you write a book and all that stuff. And so I kept in doing motivation speeches all over the world, kind of like the ex-presidents to the Gondas speaking circuit,
有太多人迷失了方向，没有真正的目标或使命。我只是非常强烈地感觉到，当我们有一个使命时，当你早上带着使命起床时，当你早上带着使命起床，当你早上带着目标起床时，是的，我们知道我们在追求什么，无论它有多难。因为你之前提到了，但这在健身房锻炼真的很难。我期待着那个，因为我觉得大脑就像一块肌肉，我们给它的阻力越大，我们挣扎得越多，我们就变得越好，我们就变得越强。我认为这就是它的全部意义。所以我们不会抱怨那个，但我们可以面对各种挑战。
you know, you make some good money with that, and you can reach a lot of people. And out of that came then this book. So this is the new thing now that I'm really into is, how do we help people? Because there's so many people that are unhappy. There's so many people that are on drugs to get happier.
并面对失败、损失，因为你会失败。我在电影中失败过很多次，我在政治中失败过很多次，但你知道，我总是会站起来，拍掉身上的灰尘，并因此变得更强。所以我想教给其他人。他们如何获得快乐，如何变得成功？这就是《Be Useful》（有用）这本书的全部内容。是的，有用。
There's so many people that are lost, that don't have a real goal or a mission. And I just feel very, very strongly that when we have a mission, when you get up in the morning with a mission, and when you get up in the morning with a mission and when you get up in the morning with a purpose Yeah, there'd be no what we're going after what we're chasing no matter how hard it is Because you mentioned earlier, but this is really hard to go in the gym of the workout I look forward to that because I feel that the brain is kind of like a muscle the more Resistance we give it and the more we struggle the better we get and the stronger we get. And I think that's what it's all about. So we don't win about that and everything, but we can confront kind of challenges.
人生的七个工具，这太棒了。我只想说，阿诺，顺便说一句，杰森刚给我发短信，他说：“他们做一磅的哑铃吗？他们做一磅的吗？”我当时想，什么，那太疯狂了。但我的意思是，他字面上……我喜欢做很多次重复。
And confront the white bouts, the losses, because you fail. I failed many times and movies, I failed in politics many times, but you know, I always kind of get up and dust myself off and get stronger with that. So I want to teach that to other people. How do they get happy and how do they become what's successful? And that's what the book be useful is all about. Yeah, be useful.
你知道，这太可悲了。我不相信杰森会问那个问题。不，这是真的。杰森可能是在问相反的问题，说：“他们做50磅的哑铃吗？”我做的全是有氧运动。我过去，我生活了很多，我经常去健身房。
Seven tools for life, which is amazing. And I would just say Arnold on the side, Jason just texted me and he said, do they make dumbbells in a one pound? Do they make it in the one pound? And I was like, what, that's crazy. But I mean, he literally, it's been- I like to do a lot of reps.
你看不出来，这里的灯光不太好，但我确实经常去健身房，为了……你应该知道。好吧，我想问你的最后一件事，阿诺，我的意思是，老实说，你做过的事情有无穷无尽的宝库，我很想和你聊聊。你的友谊，潜在的友谊，但肯定是在职业上与吉姆·卡梅隆（Jim Cameron）的关系。你第一次见到詹姆斯·卡梅隆是什么时候？那一刻是什么样的？
You know, it's so sad. I don't believe that Jason was asking that question. No, it's true. Jason was probably asking the opposite question in saying, do they make dumbbells, they're down in 50 pounds? All I do is cardio. I used, I lived a lot of, I go to the gym a lot.
因为你们显然在一起有过一段不可思议的经历。是的，我的意思是，吉姆，我见到他的时候，他只拍过一部电影。他推销了，你知道，他和我谈了《终结者》，第一部《终结者》。我当时实际上是去面试扮演里斯（Reese），扮演那个英雄角色。通过某种方式，我对终结者这个角色表现出了太多的热情，并一直对他说，无论谁扮演那个角色……因为我认为O.J.辛普森被选中了，虽然还没有签合同，但已经被选中扮演终结者。所以他试图说服我扮演……
You can't tell the lighting's not great here, but I do go to the gym a lot for, you know, you should just know. Okay, the last thing I want to ask you, Arnold, I mean, honestly, there's just such an endless well of stuff that you've done that I'd love to talk to you about. Your friendship, potential friendship, but certainly working professional relationship with Jim Cameron. When did you first meet James Cameron? What was that moment?
你看不出来这里的灯光不太好，但我确实经常去健身房，你知道的，你只需要知道这一点。好吧，阿诺德，我想问你的最后一件事，说实话，你做过的事情简直多得数不胜数，我很想和你聊聊。你和吉姆·卡梅隆的友谊，潜在的友谊，但肯定有职业上的合作关系。你第一次见到詹姆斯·卡梅隆是什么时候？那一刻是怎样的？
Because you guys obviously had an incredible run together. Yeah, I mean, Jim, at the time when I met him, he only has done one movie. And he pitched, you know, he talked to me about Terminator, the first Terminator. And I was actually going for the interview to play Rees, to play the heroic character. And through some kind of a, I showed a little bit too much enthusiasm about the character of Terminator and kept saying to him, whoever placed that character because I think Ocee Simpson was cast, not yet a contract sign, but was cast already to play Ocee to terminator. So he was trying to talk me into playing the
因为你们显然有过一段不可思议的合作经历。是的，我是说，吉姆，我见到他的时候，他只拍过一部电影。他向我推销，你知道，他和我谈了《终结者》，第一部《终结者》。我当时去面试是为了扮演里斯，那个英雄角色。通过某种方式，我对终结者这个角色表现出了太多的热情，并一直对他说，无论谁扮演那个角色，因为我想O·J·辛普森已经被选中了，虽然合同还没签，但已经确定由他来扮演终结者。所以他当时正试图说服我扮演
Terminator and I said, now I want to play Reese. And he says, no, you understand the Terminator and I said, now I want to play Reese. And he says, no, no, you understand the Terminator. You talk about that he has to walk like a machine and he has to kind of turn his head like a machine, he has to kind of like prep, take the guns apart and putting them back together, blindfolded, notice, this is all great stuff. He says, that's exactly what he has to do. And so anyway, he talked me into it. I played the Terminator. And the rest is history, you know, the movie was highly successful. And it was, of course, very, very smartly written. I mean, he himself described, he himself described it as an almost an indie film, because he wrote it in his part of it in his car. And that was weird. It was wild. Yeah, absolutely.
终结者，我说，现在我想演里斯。他说，不，你得理解终结者。我说，现在我想演里斯。他说，不，不，你得理解终结者。你说他必须像机器一样走路，他必须像机器一样转头，他必须像那样准备，蒙着眼睛拆卸和组装枪支，注意，这些都很棒。他说，这正是他必须做的。总之，他还是说服了我。我演了终结者。剩下的就是历史了，你知道，这部电影非常成功。当然，剧本写得非常非常聪明。我的意思是，他自己描述说，他自己描述它几乎是一部独立电影，因为他是在车里写了一部分。这很奇怪。这很疯狂。是的，绝对是。
Absolutely. But anyway, so then we did the Terminator 2 that became the highest-grossing movie of He wrote it in his part of it in his car and that was a weird, it was wild. Yeah, no, absolutely. But anyway, so then we did a terminated tool that became the highest-grossing movie of the year and we did the true lies and that also made like $150 million worldwide. So it was really, I had a great, great streak of movies that we did together and he was an excellent director, very demanding. I have to say, and very, very, very smart. He's one of those guys that he wants to film something a certain way, but there is no equipment around like that,
绝对是。但不管怎样，后来我们拍了《终结者2》，它成为了年度票房最高的电影。他在车里写了一部分，这很奇怪，很疯狂。是的，不，绝对是。但不管怎样，后来我们拍了《终结者2》，它成为了年度票房最高的电影，我们还拍了《真实的谎言》，那部电影在全球也赚了大约1.5亿美元。所以，我确实和他在电影上合作得非常非常顺利，他是一位出色的导演，要求非常高。我必须说，而且非常非常聪明。他是那种如果他想以某种方式拍摄某样东西，但周围没有那样的设备的人，
no camera that could do that, then he would develop it. He would develop the camera. You know, when he went down and he developed this kind of submarine to go down the ocean to the Titanic and to look inside the Titanic, he went with his vehicle, inside the Titanic to go and to really be able to make the film Titanic in the best possible way. So that's the way he is. He just develops it.
没有摄像机能做到这一点，那么他就会开发它。他会开发那台摄像机。你知道，当他潜入深海去拍摄《泰坦尼克号》并观察《泰坦尼克号》内部时，他带着他的载人潜水器进入了《泰坦尼克号》，为了真正能够以最好的方式制作《泰坦尼克号》这部电影。这就是他的风格。他只是去开发它。
I mean, he's just a genius. And in everything he does, he also helped me a lot with the environmental stuff that I did here in California and worldwide. We have given speeches about the environment, not that he's really into the reducing of pollution. And to clean up the world and make the world a healthy place, he's also very heavily into a vegan. He's a vegan for the last 10 years already, and hasn't eaten any meat because he feels like the producing of livestock creates the pollution, 28% of the pollution comes.
我的意思是，他简直是个天才。在他所做的一切事情中，他还给了我很多关于我在加州和全球所做的环保方面的帮助。我们发表过关于环境的演讲，并不是说他真的热衷于减少污染。为了净化世界，让世界成为一个健康的地方，他也非常热衷于素食。他已经吃素10年了，没有吃过任何肉，因为他觉得畜牧业生产造成了污染，28%的污染来自那里。
He shouldn't come to your house then. Yeah, we can run over by advice. I actually got off meat, at least 70% of the meat, I do eat steaks every so often, still in the finish and it's all in stuff like that. But I've reduced my meat intake considerably. It's much healthier because of it. I could listen to you say son of a bitch
那他不应该去你家。是的，我们可以被建议压倒。实际上我戒了肉，至少70%的肉，我偶尔还是会吃牛排，在终点线之类的东西里。但我已经大大减少了肉类的摄入量。因此它健康多了。我可以听你说“混蛋”
and venerate central all. I know. I know. I'm going to get to the chopper. I know. I know. We have, you're a very busy man. You have a lot of animals that you need to tend to.
和崇拜中心。我知道。我知道。我要去直升机那里了。我知道。我知道。我们有，你是一个非常忙碌的人。你有很多动物需要照顾。
Go see them. But thank you for taking the time and talking to us and so much success and congratulations on everything, including your book, which is just amazing, be useful, seven tools for life that's out now. Just so happy for you. And again, just such an honor to have you here with us. Thank you for doing this.
去看看它们吧。但谢谢你抽出时间与我们交谈，祝你取得巨大成功，并祝贺你所做的一切，包括你的书，那真是太棒了，《Be Useful: Seven Tools for Life》现在已经出版了。真为你高兴。再次感谢，能请你来这里真是我们的荣幸。谢谢你做这一切。
Thanks for doing it. This guy is Jason Sean Will. I just want to tell you that it was such a pleasure to be interviewed by three brilliant actors like you. And so it was an honor for me to do this. And I had a great time. I really enjoyed every minute of it. So thank you very much. Thank you very, very much. Thank you. Thank you. Bye bye. Be good. See you. Bye. Wow. How cool was that? Nice guest, Willie. Wow. Right. And that's pretty cool. Sean, you know, I actually kind of didn't bring this up. And I'm sure we have lots of fans who I was because I see sometimes in the comments, like, well, you got to mention that you know the thing and you said to know it all, but I did
谢谢你们做的一切。这位是杰森·肖恩·威尔。我只想说，能被你们三位出色的演员采访真是太荣幸了。所以对我来说，做这件事是一种荣誉。我度过了一段美好的时光。我真的很享受其中的每一分钟。所以非常感谢你们。非常非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。再见。保重。再见。再见。哇。那太酷了，对吧？不错的嘉宾，威利。哇。对吧。那真的很酷。肖恩，你知道，我其实没提这个。我相信我们有很多粉丝，因为我有时在评论里看到，比如，好吧，你得提到你知道那件事，你说你知道一切，但我确实
meet him once at your house. Oh, that's right. You're here to go. Remember you had that poker tournament in your backyard? Yeah, I was 1999 or 2000 or something like that. Something crazy. Yeah, it was crazy. Yeah, he came over and he, yeah.
在你家见过他一次。哦，对了。你在这里。记得你在后院举办的那场扑克锦标赛吗？是的，那是1999年或2000年左右。有些疯狂。是的，那很疯狂。是的，他来了，他，是的。
No, 2004. 2004, oh, wow. I had it. I think you could make a real argument that that's the biggest star we've ever had on this show. I mean, like you name me one person, more recognizable, more famous, or the biggest sort of like, the quintessential star, you know, like that's known that every country he goes to. Like from the time that the three of us were teenagers into our into our late
不，2004年。2004年，哦，哇。我有过。我想你可以说他是我们节目中出现过的最大牌的明星。我的意思是，你给我说出一个更具辨识度、更出名的人，或者那种最典型的明星，你知道，就像他在每个国家都很有名一样。从我们三个十几岁到我们二十多岁的时候
20s. Yeah. And if anybody had said to us, like, who's the biggest movie star in the world? You'd say for sure. It's crazy. What a career that guy is. Unbelievable. I know. Pretty remarkable. He's very inspiring from some lake in Austria because like, you know, the most world famous bodybuilder ever, then the governor, two times governor. Two times governor. Yeah, of this state, as he said, the fifth largest economy, blah, blah, blah. He's just, and a guy who really was right down the middle of his politics.
是的。如果有人问我们，谁是世界上最伟大的电影明星？你肯定会说是他。这太疯狂了。那家伙的职业生涯真是不可思议。难以置信。我知道。非常了不起。他来自奥地利的一个湖边，这很鼓舞人心，因为你知道，他是史上最著名的健美运动员，然后是州长，两届州长。两届州长。是的，正如他所说，这个州是第五大经济体，等等等等。他只是，而且是一个政治立场非常中立的人。
Yeah, you know. It's just incredible. And everything he did, and yeah, it's pretty remarkable to watch. And like you said, Jason, very humble beginnings, like doing like strong man competitions against the next town. Yeah. Like not even bodybuilding. And, but, you know, and I know he doesn't work out in the same way these days, but I bet
是的，你知道。这真是不可思议。他所做的一切，是的，看着这一切真是太了不起了。就像你说的，杰森，出身非常卑微，比如在邻镇参加大力士比赛。是的。甚至不是健美。但是，你知道，我知道他现在锻炼的方式不一样了，但我敢打赌
you he's still got some pretty good looking. Bye. See you. See you. See you. See you. See you. See you. I bet you he's still got some pretty good looking. Bye! Bye, Seth! Oh, that's not good. I'll do that one with God. Smart. Smart.
他依然看起来很不错。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。我敢打赌他依然看起来很不错。再见！再见，塞斯！哦，那不好。我会和上帝一起做那个。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grantary.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartLess是由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Grantary手工制作的100%有机节目。
If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wundri Plus in the Wundri app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com-slave-survey. called over the top and we cover the biggest topics in sports and pop culture using royal rumble rules. That means we'll start with two stories. Toss one out on its ass and dive into the other stories with ruthless aggression. Oh, but it never stops because every 90 seconds after that.
如果你喜欢SmartLess，现在就可以通过在Wundri应用程序或Apple Podcasts上加入Wundri Plus来提前收听无广告版本。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上收听无广告版本。在你离开之前，请通过在Wondry.com-slave-survey填写一份简短的调查问卷来告诉我们关于你自己的信息。节目叫《Over the Top》，我们使用皇家大战规则涵盖体育和流行文化中最大的话题。这意味着我们将从两个故事开始。把一个扔出去，然后以无情的侵略性深入探讨其他故事。哦，但这永远不会停止，因为在那之后的每90秒。
While God, whose music is that? Another story comes down to the ring. Rinse and repeat until we arrive at the one most important thing on planet Earth that week. Follow over the top on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to over the top early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus. For the record, this is not a wrestling podcast. No, no, but it is inspired by wrestling. Isn't everything inspired by wrestling, Beetle? Fair point.
天哪，那是谁的音乐？另一个故事进入擂台。重复这个过程，直到我们得出那周地球上最重要的一件事。在Wondry应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方关注《Over the Top》。你可以通过加入Wondry Plus提前收听《Over the Top》的无广告版本。郑重声明，这不是一个摔跤播客。不，不，但它的灵感确实来自摔跤。难道不是所有东西的灵感都来自摔跤吗，甲壳虫？有道理。
Yeah! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的！这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。